hey guys it's justine and wwdc 2022
is it's actually here i'm actually
shocked because i don't even know where
this year went the fact that it is
already june is beyond my
comprehension i can't believe it it's
also really wild to think that for the
past couple of years wwdc has been all
strictly online and not just wwdc
basically every single event that any
tech company has done it's all been
virtual while leading off this year with
one of the biggest events was google i o
and google decided to have it in person
there was a ton of code precautions put
in place that they were able to have
this event and it looks like
apple is having a select group of media
attend this year and i could not be more
excited like i'm trying to keep calm
because sometimes my excitedness comes
off a little aggressive so this is me
playing the part of a calm person who is
going to be going to wwdc this year i am
so excited i just think back to the
first wwdc that i went to and it was
everything that i could have ever hoped
for it was a dream come true as a child
that's all i ever wanted to do i wanted
to live i wanted to be in cupertino i
wanted to be near apple campus and now
as an adult i don't know if that's you
know i don't think i want to actually
live next door to the apple campus but
it has been really fun to get a chance
to go to apple and really experience it
firsthand so super grateful and the fact
that there will be some people in
attendance at wwdc this year is a very
very exciting enough of that of course
you guys will see a bunch of my posts so
be sure to follow me on twitter and
instagram and all of the places where
i'll be posting wwdc updates but today
we're going to talk about some rumors
and i feel like at this point we kind of
know what to expect at wwdc it is a
developer's conference this is an event
that sets up the next year the next two
years of software to get developers
thinking about ways to start
implementing all of these new features
into the software that they're creating
i feel like one of the
highlights for me is the latest ios
updates and ios 16 and yes ios 16 will
be the next release that is coming out
and ah that's wild like 16 ios releases
i feel like this video is just going to
turn into a little jaunt down memory
lane of how did we get here is this what
it's like to get old to sort of reflect
on your past life except i'm not
reflecting on life i'm reflecting on all
of the past ios systems that i have used
and all of the features and all of the
upgrades in each one so i mean maybe my
perspective is a little skewed
are we surprised and new so of course i
am on mac rumors right now one of my
favorite websites to get all of the
latest mac news mac rumors it's
literally called mac rumors and i've
been on this website since a child like
i was a child reading this website from
my parents i don't want to say actually
it was in their basement that's a whole
other story they put the computer in the
basement because i was misbehaving and
they thought that it was like a
punishment but man i freaking loved
being in the basement i had a recliner
chair i had privacy i could play my
music loud so what they thought was a
punishment and then i wouldn't want to
go and be on the computer it was
actually a vacation
how long has this video been going have
i talked about anything yet it's really
hard to say so at the time of recording
this on mac rumors it's interesting
because in past years they're stating
that ios has leaked early but this year
it hasn't happened yet but here are some
of the new rumored features that they
are thinking that we'll be seeing we'll
see overhaul block screens with
wallpapers that have widget-like
capabilities because i do feel like the
apple lock screens are kind of i mean
they're not really that engaging you
have your notifications you have your
time so to be able to update those lock
screens and customize it yeah i'm into
that significant improvements in
notifications they don't have specific
details we
love a significant update the messages
app with social network like
functionality with specific feature on
audio messages i okay we need to talk uh
i'll continue in a second but i have
this crippling panic when somebody sends
me an audio message because it doesn't
transcribe it and i
don't like to listen to messages i don't
like voicemail i don't like phone calls
to be honest with you so when i get a a
voice memo it's like a tiny voicemail
it's basically a voicemail but it's a
tiny one but sometimes it's very long
and if i listen to it and i don't click
so that it doesn't expire i then don't
remember what this person said and the
fact that it doesn't transcribe it i
can't remember it so in my mind it's
like it never happened so what i tend to
do is if someone sends me one and
apologies to any of my friends watching
this and you've sent me a voice memo and
i probably didn't listen to it out of
fear out of panic and it's the weirdest
thing i can't even explain it but
honestly anytime someone sends one i'm
just like
i just think that they should be
transcribed like voicemails because then
i can decide if i want to listen to it
or not anyway we're on to only the
fourth bullet point health app with
expanded sleep tracking functionality
and medicine management that's
interesting apple is working on a tool
that will let users scan their pill
bottles into the app plus there's a new
women's health feature expected so this
is cool i'm into this because i would
love if you could scan the pills and it
would give you a notification of when
you're supposed to take it and then you
can check off be like yes i took this
having recently now a a person who is on
blood thinners that i have to take twice
a day i normally almost always remember
but over the past two months there's
been one time that i forgot because i
just fell asleep and completely forgot
to take it if there is this sort of
check-in option that's like hey have you
taken your blood thinners yet today and
i don't click it it can keep sending you
reminders that would be awesome some new
apple apps are in the work they're also
working on new ways of system
interaction not quite clear what that
means i don't know either new fitness
plus workout types oh freaking yes apple
music classical app with interface based
on
i don't know what that is to be honest
with you next we have some possible
features on iphone 14 rumors yeah we
read that right iphone 14 it's going to
be here before you guys know it you're
going to see your feeds spammed with
ijustine iphone content as per usual and
i cannot wait so there's always on
display for iphone 14 pro and promax a
revamped status bar interface to
accommodate the hole punch and pill
design that is expected to replace the
notch which is it's here it's time i
think that the notch may finally we may
say bye bye bye a car crash detection
feature which would dial emergency
services when a collision is detected
this would require a new ios 16
functionality this is something that i'm
interested in apple may add a satellite
based emergency feature to iphone 14
which would be supported in ios 16. i
have spent so much money on a monthly
gps service from garmin just to have as
like a just in case as an emergency when
i hike thankfully i've never had to use
it i almost had to once and i got this
thing after i got stranded
in
this crazy hike in the middle of the
night we didn't make it back didn't have
any cell reception i was like that is
something that i need to invest in so if
that is something that apple is thinking
about doing or has plans maybe not this
specific release on iphone 14 but maybe
in the future um so here for it
definitely think it's a great idea but
also satellite coverage would probably
be an additional fee so i feel like that
would be something
additional that you would have to pay
for it wouldn't probably be a package
deal with any of your service providers
ios 16 could include support for buy now
pay later feature for apple pay could
introduce support for a hardware
subscription program that will let
customers pay a monthly fee for iphone
ipad imac next we have ipad os 16 saying
that ipad os will get many of the
features that were introduced in ios 16
but apple is also working on additional
functionality that is ipad specific what
could it be i love my ipad i know i've
talked about this uh in some previous
videos but i have been using my ipad so
much more this year for drawing and
doing illustration work i've been
working on this nft project it's called
at jpg well it's just called jpeg not at
but there's an app in front of it if you
want to follow it on twitter and
instagram it's jpeg.farm so kind of just
using the ipad and learning to use
procreate and illustrate and it's just
sort of been this new fun skill that
i've kind of developed over the past
couple of months and it's been so fun
they're also saying with ipad os 16
they're trying to make the ipad behave a
little bit more like a laptop than a
smartphone with new ipad software this
will be one of the biggest updates
announced at wwdc i like the way that my
ipad works i feel like if we're gonna
start making the ipad more like a mac
maybe we should also make the mac more
like an ipad so that i have a touch
screen on the mac
why not there's still two very different
devices i also love the magic keyboard
but this magic keyboard is not good if
you want to put this on your lap and
type and take notes that's been
something that i've kind of been
struggling with so i feel like a new
magic keyboard design would be something
that i would absolutely love to see
because i love the magic keyboard i love
the keyboard i love the trackpad i love
having that additional usbc port but it
needs to have better balance especially
for the pro we're also talking about
some potential updates to a redesigned
multitasking interface to make it easier
to switch between tasks to see which
apps are open you can resize windows and
apple also plans to implement new ways
for users to deal with multiple apps at
once yeah we're gonna we're gonna make
the ipad into a mac and then the mac
into an ipad and then basically we'll
have two separate things so just kind of
like doing a flat computer or do you
want a laptop i don't know mac os 13 so
what do we think the mac os 13 is going
to be called so it's not too much that
has leaked so far about mac os 13 but
they're saying there's going to be a new
system preferences revamp some of the
default apps improvements to messages
mail safari messages in particular is
rumored to be getting social networking
functions as we talked about in ios 16.
i wonder what that could be i don't know
but i'm excited about it here's a rumor
for the naming convention of the new mac
os 13 mammoth so saying way back in 2013
registered trademarks for a lot of
california landmarks and mammoth is one
that has not been used so my friends
could it be
watch os 9 freaking love my apple watch
oh just
i'm always so excited when there's any
new apple watch updates updated power
saving mode that will allow for the use
of apps and features while cutting down
on battery usage expanded atrial
fibrillation detection feature with
added burden how often a person is in a
state of atrial fibrillation across a
period of time i love my apple watch if
i mentioned that absolutely love it i
think it's such an incredible device and
this paired with my aura ring i mean
these are my two favorite tech devices
other than my iphone like i just feel
like this helps keep me on track keeping
my steps it also is very good at letting
me know when i feel a little stressed
out it's like hey maybe you should take
a breath and like oh you're right i
should improved health and activity
tracking more workout types additional
metrics for running workouts and a
refresh for existing watch faces tvos 16
it says tvos doesn't often get as many
features as other system updates you may
be able to do more with your smart home
products through apple tv following the
launch of an update love that there have
been a ton of rumors of will there be
some hardware announcements at wwdc now
this would not be the first time that
we've had a hardware announcement so if
you guys remember back in 2019 which was
actually in wwdc that i was at when they
announced the mac pro which was so
exciting you may remember at the spring
event that they
announced the mac studio which is such
an incredible powerful little device but
they were like hey yeah you think that's
cool hold on a second you haven't seen
anything yet because the mac pro
is coming soon
so maybe they'll give us a small preview
i mean if they gave us that kind of
little tease at the spring event then
maybe they'll give us a little bit more
i don't know i'm hoping i don't know
it's hard to say we really don't know
i'm literally just i know as much as you
do now you know what i know because i've
read it on the internet
don't always believe everything that you
read on the internet speaking of things
that you shouldn't believe i'll just
continue to read some more rumors
they're suggesting the mac pro will
feature a chip even more powerful than
the m1 ultra used in the mac studio it's
expected to feature 40 cpu cores and 128
graphics cores which would make it twice
as powerful as the m1 ultra at some
point just do my job for me speak just
be me just be me i can't be myself
you're too powerful just do my job for
me they're also saying that apple could
introduce an m1 ultra successor that is
in fact two m1 ultra chips linked
together because the m1 ultra is
essentially just two m1 max chips
connected together so like why don't we
just keep this going it's just like a
little puzzle a very complex beautiful
puzzle so mac rumors is seeming to think
that if they are going to introduce any
hardware that it's going to be the
macbook air they are reportedly aiming
to introduce the macbook air at the
event but covert related supply chain
issues in china could prevent them from
doing so the next-gen macbook air is
expected to feature a total design
overhaul with a mac pro like shape that
does away with the tapered body i like
the tapered body it'll be thinner and
lighter we like that it's expected to
come in multiple colors we like that
macbook air is expected to feature slim
off-white bezels and a matching
off-white keyboard oh so kind of sort of
looking like the new imac the m1 it's
beautiful just love those things it'll
probably be equipped with the next-gen
m2 chip of course it'll have speed
improvements rumored to have improved
graphics the m2 chip would be the first
upgrade after the m1 so i think that we
kind of thought that they were going to
announce the m2 but instead they went
with the m1 ultra so we kind of skipped
that so i feel like now we're kind of in
that phase where the m2 would make sense
and i feel like starting that with a
macbook air would also make sense so
that we can then go from the m2 and
basically go through that whole refresh
cycle of all of the devices throughout
next year does that make sense are you
following i'm following i see you those
supply chain issues could hinder the
release of this or their plans to put
the m2 in the macbook air hard to say we
will know soon enough and i cannot wait
and last but not least
ar vr headsets it has been rumored for a
really long time but what will it look
like will it be something like this kind
of like the oculus or will it be
something just sort of like simple
glasses that it kind of augments what
you see they can be fashionable they
don't have to look like an actual
headset because i
almost think that i'm going to prefer
for like a daily kind of just something
that i'm going to want to wear i don't
want to be in vr i'd like to be in my
kind of space don't get me wrong i like
vr but until it's done
properly where i don't feel like i'm
going to throw up and
i can actually last in it longer than a
couple of hours i've tried i've started
working my way up to trying to get used
to it but it's still very very tough so
i feel like if you do have a sensitivity
to motion that's going to be the hurdle
and the challenge in the upcoming years
is how do we make this accessible to
more people who are sensitive to these
types of things even with google glass i
do remember that there was kind of like
a learning curve too like i started
getting headaches because of like the
focus distance that you had to focus on
like a little eyepiece that was sort of
close to your eye so if i'm looking at
you guys far away i would then have to
sort of shift my gaze up but then focus
close up so it's like this weird kind of
thing that is not natural at all so i'm
excited to see kind of what apple
decides to to come up with to sort of
make this something that's comfortable
for users a trademark for reality os
which is the operating system for the
headset was discovered recently
it features a forward filing date
deadline of june 8 2022 that's a legal
requirement and it appears that the date
is unrelated to wwc it's a coincidence
is it a coincidence is it i'm gonna ask
it again is it a coincidence
well that about sums up some of the
rumors that people have been talking
about most specifically here on mac
rumors and i'm very excited for the
event of course like i said in the
beginning make sure you guys follow me
so you'll see all of my posts i'm very
excited to see some new faces and some
old friends at wwdc and i can't believe
it's going to be here before we know it
let me know in the comments below if
there's anything that you're looking
forward to what rumors have you heard
and do you think there's going to be a
hardware announcement if so what do you
think it's going to be leave me those
comments below and i will see you guys
in the next video
[Music]
you